هاي لعبه ابني
والله لعبه اشتريت له يا بايدي
هاي لعبته
مضت الاسابيع والاشهر ولا شيء تغير
بالنسبه لعمر رحله بحثه عن ابنه التي
بداها لحظه خروجه من تحت الانقاذ ما تزال
متواصله
بعرف والله الله يرحمه بس هالولد هذا وين
راح من وين صارت اراضيه لا يكف عمر عن
التردد على ما تبقى من اطلال بيته من هنا
بدا فصلا جديدا في حياته ماتت زوجته وابنه
الثاني بين احضانه خلال زلزال السادس من
فبراير الماضي فيما دخل ابنه الثاني احمد
في عداد المفقودين والله ثلاثه اشهر
فصلت عليه بكل المشافي طلعت على اضنه طلعت
على مرسين طلعت على عنتاب دورت هناك
فرجيني صور شفت كل الصور وفي كتير اولاد
اسامي مالهم بس
باداره الموتى اكبر دليل الورقه
طلع الدم يعني التحليل طلع بين وما بين
الولد اعطوني هالورقه بتثبتها بالنفوس
مشان
يتم البحث عليه يعني ورحت على النفوس بدي
اثبتها
قالوا لازم تجيب الولد عشان يطلع لنا
القبله والولد مو بدور نتائج الفحص الجيني
دي ان اي انعشت امال عمر في العثور على
ابنه تحصل على وثيقه تثبت ان احمد لم يكن
ضمن قائمه وفيات الزلزال الذين اخذت عينات
فحص لهم قبل دفنهم وانزل صور ابني واليوم
الانتخابات
اليوم زحمه العالم
حدا بيعرفها او حدا بيشوفه عندك
امل ممكن عليه ممكن ممكن اكيد اكيد يكثف
عمر جهوده هذه الايام لنشر صور ابنه
بالتزامن مع عوده اهالي هاتاي المؤقته
للمشاركه في الانتخابات لكن صعوبات مرتبطه
بوضعه كلاجئ سوري في تركيا تقلل من حدوده
في توسيع عمليه البحث خارج المدينه
المنكوبه اذ يحتاج الى تسويه اقامته
ليتمكن من مواصله رحله بحثه عن ابنه مع
مختلف المؤسسات وفي عموم تركيا عبد القادر
خربوش العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات